[Music]
yet another valley family speaking out
after another break-in this happened
during the day a similar style to recent
break-ins that police are investigating
joe moeller joins us live in sun city
summerlin with the details joe
the burglar burglars got into a home
here in sun city summerlin at one in the
afternoon on tuesday and got away with
some valuables now there's growing
concern after a string of recent
incidents
here is
the mess that
they left linda keller says her parents
both 86 years old were gone for an hour
tuesday afternoon when someone busted
through the front door they got into the
bedroom and got off with jewelry she
says police told her it's been happening
more there's been a lot of break-ins up
here
a house down on the corner just two
weeks ago broken into poor dad living
here by himself what would have happened
eight news now has been contacted
recently regarding similar incidents
this was just two weeks ago in spring
valley thieves breaking in through the
front door in a similar way
now back out here live we did check the
crime map as well there was a handful of
incidents that happened in this area
keller said she wanted to share her
story to make sure others are vigilant
during this time she says she heard of
another break-in on the same day
happened in the same neighborhood
reporting live in sun city summerlin
this evening joe muller live local now